the anti-trump forces in the media are
pretending to be really distraught about
yesterday's resignation of Secretary of
Defense Jim mattis the sky is falling
there's chaos in Washington the only
adult has left the room you've heard the
echoes beware a political earthquake is
rolling through Washington as the Trump
administration sinks further into chaos
there are no more girl Mart grown-ups in
the room you have America mica in
retreat across the globe and the most
extraordinary resignation in modern
American history certainly in the past
40 years the Democrats on the hill who
for ten years we're demanding our troops
come home from Iraq they now sound like
they went to the Paul Wolfowitz school
of foreign policy I think this will be
considered one of the worst foreign
policy blunders of this century
certainly of this century today know who
knows why the president is making this
decision today the way that he did it is
totally hand handed and it does make the
country weaker a decision made in a
Cavalier fashion in terms of our allies
in the fight against terrorism a
decision that is dangerous I'm
thoroughly confused now didn't they
elect Obama not once but twice in part
based on his pledge to bring the troops
home over the last decade we have spent
a trillion dollars on war at a time of
rising debt and hard economic times now
we must invest in America's greatest
resource our people we must unleash
innovation that creates new jobs and
industries while living within our means
America it is time to focus on nation
building here at home oh I want to stand
up and cheer in fact at one point in
2011 Pelosi and other top Democrats were
criticizing Obama for the slow pace of
his troop withdrawal many of us would
like to see this go faster than the path
that was laid out however it may and
with the proper progress whether it's
the civilian side on the governance side
on the anti-corruption side it may well
be that we can have a quicker drawdown
she's very impatient for the drawdown
there but when Donald Trump is president
all the old principles of the Democrat
Party they fly out the window now
further I think it's wise to focus on
the substance in Madison's letter where
he claimed for instance our strength as
a nation is inextricably linked to the
strength of our unique and comprehensive
system of alliances and partnerships
while the US remains the indispensable
nation in the free world we cannot
protect our interests or serve that role
effectively without maintaining strong
alliances and showing respect to those
allies well before we rush to engrave
those words on a tablet and Independence
Hall now let's think about mattis's
claim there while his deep and abiding
sense of public service and military
heroism is inspiring we all love that
part of mattis the argument that
America's strength is in our alliances
kind of stands in contrast to what our
framers believed I reread George
Washington's farewell address believing
that I'm not on the plane on the way
down here and all Americans should read
it I think at least a few times a year
it's stunningly beautiful it's wise it's
humble and in many ways it's prophetic
now mattis is a guy who himself is
steeped in military history
he knows that Washington warned against
entanglements abroad that would
ultimately put our nation at home at
risk and it wouldn't end up safeguarding
the country's fragile independence he
said the following it is our true policy
to steer clear of permanent alliance
with any portion of the foreign world
Wow it's hard too hard to take that in
now right that's what Washington said
but remember Thomas Jefferson echoed the
same sentiment in his own inaugural
message he said peace Commerce and
honest friendship with all nations
entangling alliances with none
Washington also warned us to quote avoid
the necessity of those overgrown
military establishments which under any
form of government are inauspicious to
Liberty and which are to be rewarded as
particularly hostile to Republican
liberty of course the point would be
driven home 161 years later after World
War two and after the Korean War by
President Eisenhower in his own farewell
address he said we must guard against
the acquisition of unwarranted influence
whether sought or unsought by the
military-industrial complex now I'm not
here tonight to say we shouldn't work
with other countries of course we do and
we should and we should live up to our
commitment to help our allies but it's
also the case they are we're not in a
financial position to rev up the Team
America world police squadrons either
and mattis has said himself including in
his resignation missive that we can't be
the policemen of the world whenever we
take action abroad especially military
action it should be based on clearly
defined goals with a specific and clear
national security objective which once
reached allows for an American
withdrawal from the region the argument
from so many of the Bush Republican
types is well we can't pull our troops
out because then chaos will ensue well
by that thinking will never leave
anywhere we deploy because chaos is
always a possibility especially in
tumultuous places like the Middle East
my friends
Dom's foreign policy is based in
principled realism not endless
interventionism we have no pressing
national security interest in Syria now
we fulfilled our objective we smashed
Isis a success that the administration
shares with general mattis